he is no.1 ads NFL Draft Scout on both
Twitter Instagram and he is the draft
expert from Bleacher Report joining us
right now here on the Rich Eisen show a
day before the NFL Draft he's Matt
Miller how are you Matt I'm doing well
rich thanks I'm you I appreciate it you
got it so now how does out of taking
Tampa out of the tight end market mess
with your mock mock draft in the fourth
or fifth round okay seven round mock
that comes out tomorrow and crazy when
the trade got leaked you know were like
Chester and everybody's tweeting about
I'm panicking right like what got traded
because I'm gonna have to redo something
right something's gonna change in a
seven or a mock draft two days before
the draft so I was so thankful that it
was a fourth and a seventh-round er like
that's easy okay I can move some things
around
no big deal if it had been a first
rounder yeah it would be I would be very
upset right now I bet I bet so um let's
let's get to what you think's gonna
happen tomorrow
it's gonna be borough young or do you
see any sort of Hail Mary happening are
you hearing of anything no I'm not it's
you know it's boring
I know for everyone who does this for a
living we would love to have some
intrigue right now but I don't think
there is any I think Joe burrow has been
the number one pick since the Bengals
earned the right to draft him first of
roll and it after that I think
Washington they probably you know kick
the tires on the quarterbacks just to
see you know just to see if there's a
guy that you like better than what you
already have once they acquired Kyle
Allen to be the backup slash competition
at quarterback I think that ended any
talk of Toula going there or Justin
Herbert or any of the other quarterback
so it feels like the first two picks
tomorrow night might be a little boring
for you guys well you know what it's
it's all good man
because these guys are some of the best
players in college football that we've
seen in the past several years and they
had two incredible years and now they're
gonna come in the NFL and well we'll
enjoy them when we get a chance to enjoy
them so third overall I give you the
choice of the Lions picking or trading
out what do you think happens
I would pick trading out I think they're
trying to generate a market right now
and I think a lot of the smoke screens
you're gonna see leaked you know over
the next
forty-eight hours will be to that point
of you know they're gonna try to
generate a market so someone comes up
for a quarterback the Dolphins have been
waiting for this moment for it feels
like two years to draft their
quarterback in the future they have
three first rounders this year to second
rounders two seconds to first rounders
next year they have 14 picks in this
draft so if they want to pop up a couple
spots from five to three to make sure
they get their guy it's not because you
have to jump the Giants it's just to
make sure that you get your guy with no
uncertainty I can see that happening and
I think the Lions are gonna be willing
to lower that price in order to do this
I don't think it would be like the the
Colts and jets trade a couple years ago
where the Colts moved back from three to
six so the Jets can get Sam darn 'old I
think the asking price to be
significantly lower than that okay so I
guess now that we're a couple minutes in
here Matt Miller or bleacher report the
intrigue is what we think it is and it's
- and the evaluation of tool and and
whether the Dolphins are putting up a
tremendously effective smoke screen
where the number of mock drafts that I'm
seeing then have Justin Herbert going to
Miami or Miami going in a different
direction of event or it's become a
cottage industry I wonder where you sit
on that subject right now everyone else
and I think I have been for quite some
time with its you know mock draft isn't
what you would do as a general manager
it's what you're hearing
Daniel Jeremiah says that better than
anyone and so when everything you're
hearing is Justin Herbert the Dolphins
like Justin Harbor they're worried about
the medicals with tua it you do wonder
because everyone's saying it so is it
either is it like Daniel Jones last year
where everyone's saying it to the point
that you start to doubt it you start to
wonder if it's true and so I've
definitely gone through that as well of
you know you put Justin Herbert there a
five and then you start to overthink it
of it's Justin Herman really Brian
Flores who's kind of guy are they really
gonna roll the dice on a guy who is I
mean he was never great college he was
pretty good his most you know his best
performances at the Senior Bowl where
it's basically a scrimmage or the
combine where it's you know you're
throwing against the air I think that is
you start to doubt that in the back
you're head of two of this you know you
know what he has a passer he's this
great passer it's drew brees s at times
but yeah there's some injury concerns
but if you just had to compare these two
his quarterbacks it's not even close to
it is so much better as a quarterback
prospect I know that the injuries come
into play and that that's also really
gonna be the deciding factor from Miami
but you're right rich every mod draft
you read and every person you talk to
around the league right now they all
feel like Miami is gonna take Justin
Harper well who was it yesterday Chris
who said Moreno was the one he's chiming
in on this front as well right it was
Bria right Albert Brewer was telling us
that he thinks that he says in his
reporting Moreno is saying that he loves
Justin Herbert a big guy with a big arm
etc and so on and so forth you know I
just can't believe that here we finally
are the Dolphins put in all the work and
by the work I mean trading everybody of
value away you know and then however
putting the their tank job in the hands
of the antitank quarterback and in fits
fits magic that they're still with all
of that here we are and it sure looks
like they're gonna have to was sitting
right there at five they won't even have
to move up to Detroit it seems like to
go get it and they might pass that way
they're gonna pass they really are I
mean I think their fans are gonna write
it if and when that happens because even
if you if you tweet I'm hearing the
Dolphins one Justin Herbert Dolphins
fans come out in machs of you don't know
you're talking about there's no way
we'll pass onto it they've had their
heart set on this quarterback for at
least a year and now you're gonna be
there he's on the clock
you didn't have to trade up you didn't
have to go winless the guy you wanted
tank for two he's there and they're not
gonna take him I think it's gonna be
it's gonna be interesting to see the
reaction when that happened okay
Matt Miller here on the Rich Eisen show
joining me the day before the National
Football League draft before we all get
ready and are in our shelter in place
for this whole for this whole
extravaganza are very excited about that
Matt Miller bleacher report on the Rich
Eisen show what happens next then so if
two is passed up on do you think the
Chargers just say their thank you and
take him six I I hope so right you know
that's where you you get to the point of
a
I think some over evaluation with tua
and the information out there right now
says they do like Tyrod Taylor I wonder
if they liked high rod so much why he
didn't play last year and I know Philip
Rivers is a future hall-of-famer and you
want to be respectful to that but you're
also trying to win football games so I
think that all this noise about they
really like Tyrod they think he could be
the guy next year they might think that
but that's also a very effective way to
put out there hey we might not draft a
quarterback so you hope one Falls to you
and so I do think the Chargers take two
up you're moving into a new stadium you
got to sell tickets you need a face of
the franchise on offense he can be that
when you're competing with the Rams in
sofa Stadium you get a guy who's from
Hawaii so there's you know kind of some
West Coast yeah routes there as well and
I do like he's the most recognizable
player in this draft it's not Joe burrow
it's not chase young it's to us he is
hands down you're playing Alabama the
stage that he played on that everyone
watches the casual play of the national
championship where he comes in at
halftime and he leaves to come back over
Georgia like to is the face of this
dressed and for the Chargers to get that
it makes sense from a business
standpoint it makes sense from a
football standpoint it's almost too good
to be true as soon as they hang up the
phone with you Matt Miller I say hello
to Isaiah Simmons who says hello to
Isaiah Simmons on Thursday night yeah
any Matt rules gonna be calling him and
number seven overall I didn't just what
an amazing player you're gonna have a
good time talking to him as well as a
great human being he I feel like another
guy it's like where do you play him play
him on defense what do you mean where do
you play him where would you place Sean
Taylor if he were in the NFL right now
that's where you play Isaiah Simmons one
week he's a safety the next week he's a
linebacker he's gonna be able to blitz
he's going to be able to stop the run I
mean this is the answer to mobile
quarterbacks this is the answer to tight
in to run a four-four in the 40-yard
dash so do the Panthers you got a head
coach and an offensive coordinator who
just came from college that offensive
coordinator saw what Isaiah Simmons did
to his LSU Tigers in the first half of
the national championship game to me
that's a slam dunk you lose Luke Kuechly
you know you Thomas Davis gone a couple
years now they have their quarterback in
Teddy they trade for an offensive tackle
and russello Combe the table set for
them to draft
Simmons and I think they're uniquely
positioned with you know some college
coaches on that staff to know how to
unleash him so that he's not just being
okay you're you're plugging you in
you're a Mike linebacker good luck
against these offensive guards they
would put him in a position to succeed
every play Matt Miller bleacher report
few minutes left with the lead NFL draft
writer bleacher report here the day
before the NFL Draft right here on the
Rich Eisen show so give me teams that
are gonna be trading up do you think for
these eight nine ten picks or maybe even
for Carolina's seventh just in case give
me give me give me what you're hearing
in the rumors of the the trade up trade
down front yeah I don't need any
surprise the Atlanta Falcons Thomas
dimitrov is one of the most aggressive
James in football so I think they would
like to trade up for CJ Henderson the
corner from Florida and this might be
the spot seven over all could be that
spot you want to get ahead of the
Jacksonville Jaguars who could also take
him if he's gone off the board I think
Jacksonville is a team that can trade
out and we could be looking at the
Broncos trading up for Jerry Judy at
wide receiver
maybe the Bucs really want to make sure
they get their offensive tackle for Tom
Brady they can trade up and try to get
one of those the top tackles before you
have that run of the Browns and Jets who
would most likely take one off the board
so those teams right right in the middle
I think the Buccaneers the Broncos the
Falcons at 14 15 16 are the most
intriguing in terms of who's gonna move
up tomorrow night
I put Trevor Lawrence in this
quarterback draft class you put him
where Matt I even he would be gosh
probably first overall he's he's
incredibly good and still getting better
I hope to god we get to see him play
college football this coming fall
because he's truly special he's a little
bit stronger than Joe burrow and a
little bit more athletic so I I do think
he would be the first pick I mean you
know Joe burrow through 60 touchdown
passes right I love Joe Burrell he's my
guy I'm a huge jobber open with that
that tells you how good Trevor Lawrence
it does right I mean like that and and
that's do you think that that is a
prevailing evaluation I think there's
right now but yeah I mean I got old
enough to remember when everybody
thought Matt Leinart was gonna be the
first you know it was like for three
years matt leinart was gonna be the
first pick in the draft and and you know
we go through these cycles of once you
get to actually break the guy down
you'll find some flaws you'll find
something you know he's a little skinny
or there'll be something but I think as
of now the the upside with Trevor
Lawrence is probably as good as you know
you have to go back to like Andrew Luck
or peyton manning where you see this guy
coming and there's just not really
anything he doesn't do well what's your
best guest where Jordan love goes I'll
say the cult maybe they have to move up
to get him but I think the Colts at 34
are a really really interesting option
where he doesn't have to play right away
and you can just let that arm shrink
develop remember ballard was in Kansas
City when they when they were all over
mahomes I know he was gone by the time
they drafted him but I think chris
ballard to look at this and say this
might be my shot to get a rare athlete
with a huge arm we could sit let him
learn and develop spur year yeah let's
let's linger on this one for a second
man
I mean here's a couple things first of
all if Jordan Love drops in the first
round is now I'm beginning to hear
that's a prevailing thought and that he
he starts getting down in the late 20s
and early 30s
somebody's gonna hop back into the first
round and make sure that they get an
extra year of contractual control on him
I don't think he's gonna fall out of the
first round just for that alone I think
somebody's gonna get it itchy about it
and say let's be smart about it let's
not wait till next let's not wait till
tomorrow not let's not give other
general managers a full night to call
everybody around and try and get him at
the top of Friday night let's go get him
now let's get an extra year of
contractual control and I don't know if
the Colts or that team because let's
just say again Malcolm what if you're
with me football goes down on time this
year they got Philip Rivers
this is the time that you got to fill it
up for Phil right now you can't just sit
he sit here and use your use your draft
choice that uh that you have that's your
best on something other than city
setting things up for Phillip to win
right now I said I I agree with that
completely the Colts have no quarterback
under roster for 2021 though no I mean
everyone's a free agent so at some point
they're gonna have to make a move and it
does not seem like Chris valor to wait
so you know what will be in next year on
Trevor Lawrence freelance Justin fields
we're gonna put all our eggs into this
we believe we can win now with Philip
Rivers all our eggs are in that basket
will fit right next year we get to next
year there are teams like that I think
Ballard is just too smart to be that guy
they pick it 34 yeah they're like you
if he starts to slide you might not have
to come up that far to get him to where
it's not completely depleting I think
they only have six choices in this trap
so you're not completely depleting your
draft reserves to go get a player that
it is it's a little bit boring because
you're drafting someone who's not
helping you this year but if for some
reason Phil goes down or plays like you
did in December you might need that
quarterback faster than you think you do
yeah that's just an interesting aspect
of the draft is just you know how far do
you have to move up and if love gets
down to say where San Francisco's I mean
the Niners would love for love to drop
right down to 31 because they're looking
to get out and start replenishing we
talked to John Lynch yesterday they
don't have a second third or fourth they
need some more second night they need a
second night pick and I think that
that's that that might be something
right there Matt Miller here on the Rich
Eisen show give me names a guys that did
or
you love that you think would be a great
selection for a team either on Thursday
night or Friday give me those names Matt
yeah Joe Broz my guy I know that he's
gonna be the first pick so that's boring
to say but I fell in love with him in
Austin Texas early September watching
him beat my beloved Texas Longhorns so
that's maybe I'm cheating on that one
but Antoine Winfield jr. from Minnesota
yeah great combine man he had a brain
rate combine grace you don't want the
Thorpe Award as well no disrespect the
great Delpit he should won the Thorpe
seven picks three sacks he was the heart
and soul of that team every time I watch
him play I think I'm watching Tyrann
Mathieu back in college it's just an
impact on every snap on defense she's a
little undersized no he was banged up in
college but he is one of those dudes I'm
gonna be rooting for no matter where he
lands because it's just a little bit of
a throwback in the way he plays and it's
infectious so you fall in love watching
his game right and like I said great
combine stellar he did everything
perfectly
that day in Indianapolis he was terrific
and what about a final day pick what do
you think fourth fifth six who's who's
sitting out there that you think whether
it's a quarterback prospect receiver
give me a couple names on that front
yeah I don't know if he'll last long
enough but I am really intrigued by
Antonio Gibson
Memphis he only touchable like 77 times
in college but he score like 14
touchdowns it's incredible place them
running back place and wide receiver so
finding the right fit for him is going
to be interesting but I wouldn't be
shocked if it's three years and we're
rewashing this draft like everyone was
last night watching the 2017 one and
saying gosh how did Antonio Gibson fall
to the you know third or fourth round
because he's it you know an instant
playmaker again whether it's running
back wide receiver has to return man I
think he's someone you just got to find
a way to get the ball in his hands and a
creative offensive coordinator is gonna
really like the traits that he's
bringing to the table
Matt appreciate the time man enjoy the
draft however you're taking it and enjoy
it yeah I appreciate that respect you
got you got it's Matt Miller hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here